news welcome back everyone with a surge  in covet cases airbnb is taking new  steps  to keep large groups from bringing in  the new year in vacation rentals  from coast to coast authorities have  been targeting people who  choose to party through the pandemic  throwing so-called covid parties that  also includes us here in las vegas  and here's more from airbnb if you're  coming to airbnb  you don't have a five-star rating and  you're seeking to do a one-night  reservation on new year's eve you're  just not gonna be able to do that  platform has been updating its policies  since the start of the pandemic  and that includes a cap on occupancy  restricting guests under 25  without a history of positive reviews  even taking legal action against those  who violate the rules  airbnb also set up a 24-hour  neighborhood support line  for people to report complaints of  parties at host sites and sheriff joe  invarda told us this morning they will  be doing that here in las vegas too